- If you don't mind my asking,
I'm really curious,
what made you start all this?
- [Mark] I'm just
fascinated with how people
tend to willingly self-destruct.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And just ruin their own lives.
And I've been fascinated with that
since I realized people
were doing it, in my life.
And even I do it to some extent.
And it's...
And the more I do it,
I've done well over 2,000
of these interviews,
- Mm-hm.
- [Mark] The more I do it,
the more I kind of get a better
grip on what's causing it,
and why people do it, and
why they can't stop doing it.
- Yeah, you see patterns.
- Y-Yeah.
There's certain things that certain parts
of their childhood,
usually, that have repeated
over and over and over.
- Yeah.
- And that's the stem of it all.
And then it just repeats
generation after generation.
- Yeah, it's crazy.
But that's super cool, yeah.
- [Mark] And I think we all go through it.
- Oh, yeah, in different ways.
- Everyone,
everyone to some extent.
I mean, these are maybe
the more extreme stories
on my channel,
but everybody is struggling
with this kind of stuff.
- Yeah, yeah.
- To some extent.
So that's why-
- Definitely.
- That's why I think it's been so popular
is because you can
relate to these stories,
even if you think you're not
a drug addict, which I'm not.
Or you're not a prostitute or whatever
but that self-destruction is
something that we all have.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And it can be,
there's so many different
ways it plays out,
whether it's, you know,
drugs or alcohol or gambling
or shopping or laziness or, (chuckling)
or just your personalities
pushes people away or anything.
- Yeah.
- So.
- Exactly.
- [Mark] So that's what got me doing it.
- That's so cool, yeah.
- [Mark] All right, Scarlett.
Scarlett, where are you from?
Where'd you grow up?
- I was born in Oregon
but I kind of moved all
over the country as a kid.
I moved to North Carolina,
Virginia, Montana,
but I mostly grew up in LA, Los Angeles.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- Yeah, so I was born,
my parents got divorced
when I was in kindergarten
but up until then, I don't
really remember much.
So up until I was six,
I don't remember much.
And then once my parents got divorced
my dad moved me and my three
siblings to California.
'Cause we were all born in Oregon.
And he got remarried
because he was having
an affair with my mom,
and that's what caused the divorce.
And then the woman he was
having an affair with,
eventually became our
step-mom, me and my siblings.
And, yeah.
(chuckling)
- How would you describe your childhood?
- Confusing.
Very confusing.
A lot of, I was told to
a lot of different things
from different people.
From my mom, my dad,
step-parents, friends, relatives,
so, and they were all very opposite.
So it was hard to just figure
out what was, you know,
what was true and who was just feeding you
the right information, yeah.
- Did you finished high school?
- I didn't.
I dropped out my junior year,
because I overdosed on Xanax
in school, in history class.
And then I just, I never went back.
- So drugs kind of came into your life.
At what point?
- They came into my point.
I started drinking alcohol when I was 12.
And right as I started, I just,
it took off and it led to other things.
I was offered pills first,
before I didn't smoked weed
or anything else at school.
And that was when I was 13.
I started taking Adderall and Xanax
and that really, heavily
affected my memory,
and I started noticing that.
And I think my family and
friends started noticing that
and it started affecting my grades.
I was a really good student.
I had straight A's and then seventh grade,
everything just kind of plummeted.
Yeah.
- [Mark] So you went on
your own at what age?
- I can't really say I was on my own,
but in a way, I've been
on my own, my whole life.
I've always had some sort of parent figure
but they haven't always, even
if they've been in the house
they haven't always been there, you know?
Or they've left.
A lot of step parents.
A lot of my dad's girlfriends
were coming, then leave.
Yeah.
So it just caused a lot of, I think,
I didn't have stability ever.
- [Mark] And how old are you?
- I'm 18.
- [Mark] You're 18?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you've been
in LA for how long?
- I've been in LA, on and off,
for probably about 10 years.
- [Mark] 10 years!
So some of your family members live here?
- Yeah.
Most of my family lives down here.
My mom lives in Oregon.
My siblings all live down here.
My dad lives down here,
but I don't speak to my family.
- [Mark] Could you tell?
- No.
- [Mark] And your drug
use is kind of continued?
- Yeah, it got it.
It wasn't very, it was.
When I started,
people attributed it to
a lot of other things.
My parents,
or my dad thought I had a
lot of mental health issues.
So when I was on drugs
and I would act out,
I would be diagnosed as
bipolar, schizophrenic,
all these things, which I wasn't.
But I didn't admit that I
was using all these drugs
and all this alcohol.
And then it didn't really come to light
until I started overdosing,
and my first overdose was in eighth grade.
And then since then I've been
in rehab, on and off in jail.
Yeah.
- [Mark] What's your drug-
- Xanax.
But I've dabbled in everything.
I was on crystal for a while.
Pretty heavy.
- What kind of stuff did
you go through as a kid?
- Okay, so, the reason
my parents got divorced.
My dad had an affair
and my mom ended up finding out
that it wasn't his first affair.
And it was, he'd also had affairs
not only with random women,
but with her friends as well.
So I found that out at a really young age
and I didn't really understand.
I mean, I was six when it all happened
and I was probably about seven or eight
when I started getting all the, you know
rumors or information
about what was happening.
And it was all, again, mixed
from my mom and my dad.
This happened, this didn't happen.
So again, that was confusing.
But basically the woman my dad.
The main woman my dad had an affair with,
he ended up marrying and leaving my mom.
And then we all moved down to California,
me and my siblings.
My mom stayed back in Oregon.
So I never lived with my
mom except for up to six.
So when I was six, I didn't live with her.
So my mom stayed in Oregon.
We all moved down to California
and my step-mom ended up.
We ended up seeing just patterns
and behavior that, again,
I didn't realize what they
were because I was so young.
But she had bipolar disorder
and she was an alcoholic,
had really bad depression.
The first thing I noticed,
I was like, really?
I think the most,
the first very traumatic thing in my mind
when I think of my childhood,
is when I was woken up in
the middle of the night
by like, just so much noise
and I was really scared.
And I opened my bedroom door,
which I showed up to my little brother
and a bunch of firemen
were running up the stairs.
And one came to the door and just told me,
"Go back to sleep."
And I was like, "I'm not
gonna go back to sleep.
"There's a bunch of firemen in my house."
But I peered off the door
and I saw my step-mom
being wheeled out in a stretcher
and there was blood everywhere.
And I found out from my sister that night,
that she tried to kill
herself with scissors
when she was drunk.
So that, even though I don't
remember like the whole night
and I didn't see it happen,
it was still really traumatic.
And I didn't know, she was.
I didn't know she had any problems,
so I didn't see anything until then.
And that was kind of scary
to see at a young age.
And then I don't think she
really hit it after that.
So once we moved from,
my dad moved us from
California to North Carolina,
across the country,
when I was going into seventh
grade, I think I was 13.
And that was like a huge thing,
that I don't think we realized
at the time how big that was.
Like moving across the country, that young
and not really having a plan,
knowing nobody over there,
that's where my stepmom was from,
so she wanted to move back there.
But we ended up moving there
and I got into school there.
At my school in California,
I was, it was fine.
I had friends, you know,
I was a normal kid and everything.
And then once I got there, it was just,
I don't know what happened.
But I guess, just the new kid,
but nobody talked to
me, I was just a loner.
And I just had that label from
day one, for whatever reason.
And I wasn't, I did
not, not talk to people.
You know, I was friendly, I was outgoing,
but nobody talked to me,
nobody, for whatever reason.
I don't know why.
So for two years,
seventh and eighth grade,
I had zero friends.
I ate lunch in the bathroom.
It was really hard.
And, sorry.
During that time, a lot
of stuff was going on
at my house too.
Just a lot of, my stepmom was.
She would just come into
my room or, thank you.
Or my sister's room, my older sister
and a lot of times I would hear,
dad would be laying,
and I would hear her going
to my older sister's room
and yell at her, for no reason.
And then I would just
hear my sister crying.
And when I always talked to her about it,
she didn't say much and she
would just have panic attacks.
And so I think from.
I think from a young age
we all just kind of
had a lot thrown on us.
And so, yeah, she would
have panic attacks.
I would go into her room,
try to calm her down
and it would be over nothing.
She would go into her
room and yell at her,
calling her disgusting
because my sister has OCD.
Calling her names,
come into my room, yell at me.
Call me fat, call hideous.
Don't know why, I'm 13.
Don't know what I'm doing,
I don't have any friends at school.
And now, you know,
and my dad's not doing anything.
He's sitting right there watching it.
I don't know, just, it was hard.
And then outside of that, I,
my sister was in place.
She was in theater.
(lighter striking)
And me and my little brother
would go and watch her
at the high school, 'cause
we were in the middle school
and it was connected.
So, one night, we were watching the play
and an older boy from the high school
started talking to me.
And he got my number and
I was really excited.
I was, nobody talked to me.
No guys talked to me.
And here's this 18 year old.
He was really handsome, I remember.
And I was really excited
to get his number.
I'm thinking, "Why in the
hell is he talking to me?
"Nobody talks to me.
"He must, I don't.
"Does he not realize?
"Does he not know like who I am?
"I'm a freaking loner!"
But anyways, he texted me.
It was my first time sneaking out,
again, I thought, "Super exciting.
"Oh my gosh, I'm 13, I'm
seeking out to see a boy.
"So exciting."
I climbed out, we were in a,
our home there was really big.
We had many acres and it was,
I had to climb out, go into
logs, get out and everything.
I ended up meeting him in his car.
We drove, he said he wanted
to go to an abandoned church
where him and his
friends went to drink at.
And at that point I had been,
I'd been drinking for a
while, for about a year.
But it wasn't bad.
I was drinking, but I wasn't, you know,
I was functioning.
I was fine.
He ended up, we ended
up going to the church,
parking outside and he gave me a drink.
The drink was your
roofied, but I didn't know.
It was just, I thought it was alcohol.
So we went into the church
and I started feeling wrong, right away,
just off and unsafe.
I remember feeling very,
just like uncomfortable,
just like I wanna be home.
I wanna be just in my covers.
I don't wanna be here,
I don't know where I am.
Very weird feeling.
Never felt that, just
uncomfortable weirdness.
And then he raped me at the church.
I remember parts of it.
And I remember him,
sorry, dropping me back at my house,
and me going up to my
bathroom and just undressing
and looking at myself,
and just seeing bruises.
And I had no one to talk to.
I didn't tell anyone.
I couldn't even tell my
parents or my siblings.
And I had no friends to tell.
So I started using pills
when I was offered them,
and they became easier to get.
I became, I began knowing
more people who had them
and it was all, I just, it
just took everything away.
When I first took Xanax,
I can't even tell you who it was.
That's why it's my drug of choice.
It's the memory for me.
It takes my memory away, everything.
And even though it's not
good because it takes my,
even when I'm off of it, you know,
it affects my memory, my long-term memory.
When I'm on it, it's the best feeling
because I don't have to
think about the past,
the present, the future,
anything.
- [Mark] Hmm.
And how are you supporting yourself now?
- Right now, it's pretty difficult.
I have ways to make money,
it's just, I don't have
much money. (chuckling)
But I'd rather not get into it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
So you've been in trouble
with the law as well?
- Yes.
I caught a case when I was 17,
for carjacking and robbery.
Again, very complicated story.
I didn't.
It sounds like I just robbed
someone and jacked their car,
it's not how it went down.
That's not that type of person.
but I did take all the charges
and I was in juvie for four
months, almost four months.
And I was supposed to be
on four years probation.
And right as I got out,
I was sober for those four months in jail.
My head was clear.
I felt great.
I really did.
And I promised, I was talking to my mom.
I wasn't talking to the rest of my family
but I was talking to
my mom and it was good.
We made a plan, I was gonna
finish school, get my GED again.
I tried to get my GED before
but went on the run, didn't finish it.
We were planning everything,
getting back into rehab
and then got out of jail.
First thing I did, smoke some weed.
I said, "That's all I'm gonna
do, I'm just gonna smoke.
"That's all I'm gonna do
"because I have a drug
test in what, a month?
"I can just get out.
"Just one time, that's all."
The next day, smoke some weed,
maybe the next day, a little bit more.
And then call my Xanax plug.
And then now I'm looking for crystal.
It just, it was a whole thing.
And I couldn't, it just.
For the life of me, I don't know why.
No matter how bad I wanted
it when I was sober,
I wanted it so bad when I was in jail.
I promised myself I was
never, ever gonna use again,
ever, never, not even gonna drink.
And the first thing I did
when I got out, was do it,
not even thinking, I just did it.
Didn't even think.
So that really messed me up.
But anyways, that was very off topic.
I was supposed to be on
four years probation,
but since I did do that and I didn't stop,
again, it was on me.
I knew I was going to fail my drug test
when they screened me.
So I decided to go on the run
because if I turn myself
in, I get four years.
So, that's not what I'm trying to do.
- [Mark] So you're on the run right now?
- I am.
- [Mark] How long has this been going on?
- I've only been on the
run for about a week.
Yeah.
- [Mark] And if they find you, you're?
- Four years.
- [Mark] Four years.
- [Mark] Wow.
(lighter striking)
So do you have any friends
- That is also a loaded question.
I can't say if I have friends that.
I don't have any friends
right now, I can say-
- [Mark] Street acquaintances?
- Yeah, I don't have anyone
I can call that would,
that is in.
The only person I can
think of, that I can call,
that would do something for me is my mom
but she doesn't live near me.
She lives in another state.
- [Mark] And are you
even talking with her?
- No, I'm not.
- [Mark] You're not.
- No.
- [Mark] So what do you worry about,
what's your biggest concern?
- My biggest concern is, I guess,
just living, figuring
out if I want to live,
how much longer it goes on, how much?
Sorry, that sounds really heavy but just,
it's a lot and it's
just too much sometimes.
So I think my biggest worry is just,
when is it all just gonna stop.
And just like, when will
I get a breath, you know?
- [Mark] What emotion do
you deal with the most?
- I think, regret and sadness, probably.
- [Mark] Depression?
- Depression, definitely, yeah.
- [Mark] How bad has it gotten?
- Very bad.
Since I was young,
definitely since my parents split.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Never like suicidal or anything?
- Yup.
Yup.
A couple of times, yeah.
- [Mark] And do you make the connection
with anything in your childhood
and the situation you were in?
- Yeah, I didn't really go into a lot.
There is a lot of trauma,
a lot of abuse with step-parents,
with boys at a young age,
men at a young age.
That just, I think,
that's why when I.
A lot of things happened prior
to me taking that first drink
when I was 12,
that when I felt that first effect,
like when I felt just not exactly,
like not connected to reality.
When I felt a disconnect and I could,
I didn't have to think
about what was going on,
it was like the best feeling.
And I was only 12. (chuckling)
Like, that's really sad.
- [Mark] So the pain disappeared?
- Yeah.
It just all went away.
And then I just, it.
And then more pain added on
worst pain and it never stopped.
And then I just, I did
more drugs, more alcohol.
Everything.
- [Mark] But what kind of abuse?
- There was sexual abuse,
some physical abuse
but it was mostly emotional abuse, yeah.
In the house, yeah.
- [Mark] So it's a pretty
rough childhood you had.
- Yeah, it was...
Yeah.
- [Mark] Been living on the street,
how do you feel this has changed you?
- It was, I didn't always
live on the street.
I'm not from a bad home.
I'm not, my parents had good money-
- [Mark] Are you in a tent now?
- I am, yeah.
- [Mark] yeah.
- Part of it is, or it is my choice.
I chose to use drugs.
I chose to do all these things.
- [Mark] Are your siblings
in a similar situation?
- They're not, no.
They're all in contact.
They talk, yeah.
They live in a home. (chuckling)
- [Mark] What do you wish was different,
about your childhood or your life that-
- I wish.
- [Mark] Would make a
big difference today?
- I don't know if I would change it,
because I don't know what
I would do without it.
Like, I feel like I've
matured a lot, just,
I'm only 18 and I feel like I've just seen
and been through a lot.
Even though it's, most
of it is not good stuff
and it's not stuff that anybody,
any child or any teenager
should go through.
But a lot of things has
like molded me, you know?
And then maybe be able
to live around here.
Not to be messed with, you know?
- [Mark] It seems like once you go through
that kind of stuff, it
becomes your reality.
- Yeah, for sure.
- And it's not like you
can imagine a better life
or a life without that.
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Mark] And it becomes your world
and you almost try to recreate it,
with other abusive relationships
and stuff like that.
- For sure, yeah.
- [Mark] Do you see yourself doing that?
- I do.
I have very destructive patterns.
- [Mark] Like the guys
that you hook up with or?
- Oh yeah.
Not good. (chuckling)
Usually not good for me.
Yeah, I just don't-
- [Mark] I mean, what
I'm learning, it seems,
is a lot of these people that
have been through things,
like you have.
It's like the brain gets rewired.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what's good,
gets pushed away.
You have no use for it.
And what's bad becomes attractive.
So you end up making these bad
choices over and over again.
- Yeah, I've always wondered
why I've always, even as a kid,
I feel like I've always
gravitated towards that bad crowd.
- [Mark] Yeah and if you're offered.
And if I was to come along
and offer you a good situation
as a way out?
- I don't know if I would-
- [Mark] You wouldn't want it?
- Yeah, and I don't know why.
I honestly don't know why.
- [Mark] I've seen it so many times now,
it's become a pattern.
You either flake and just disappear,
or you get angry at me
because I represent good.
And that's just a nuisance and it's like,
it makes you feel-
- It's hard to accept.
- Makes you feel guilty for-
- I've been through
rehab, I've been through.
So I've tried.
It's very difficult.
I can never stay.
That's what, I can't, I don't.
I can't imagine my
future, a year from now.
Like, I really don't know what to expect.
And it's just really, you know
it's just kind of taking a toll.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's almost like
you need to repair it yourself.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, if you can imagine that.
- If yeah.
- [Mark] Then love yourself
and almost re rebuild your self-worth
and your subconscious almost to,
to feel like you deserve better things.
I don't know if you know that's possible,
but that's what.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's the only hope I see.
- [Mark] What's the most painful thing
that you're escaping from, you think?
- Memories. (chuckling)
- [Mark] Of the like
sexual abuse or whatever?
- Yeah, yeah.
Lots of just.
- [Mark] Just horrible.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what's the
most important lesson
you've learned?
- It sounds cliche, but
not to judge people.
Like I-
- Mm-hm, that's a good one.
- Yeah, I just try to be
friendly to everyone I meet,
no matter what they're going through.
And I've met some really kind people
in some really bad situations.
And I wouldn't have, if I
weren't in this situation myself,
so I'm grateful for that too.
That I've met some of these people.
- [Mark] Yeah, do you feel
betrayed by your family or?
- In some ways, yeah.
Some, by some people, more than others.
I don't feel angry at my family.
I'm not angry at all.
Just, I think my parent figures,
because when I say parent figures
I didn't just have my mom and dad.
I have stepmom, stepdad.
You know, my dad's
girlfriends, many girlfriends.
So I had a lot of
different parent figures,
coming in and out of my life.
And I just,
I know I'm not grown yet
but as I'm older and I can,
you know, I feel more,
I have that more motherly tent.
You know, those motherly tendencies.
I can't imagine putting
a kid through that,
like what me and my siblings went through.
I just don't understand how
a parent can like sit or eat,
even if certain ones didn't inflict it,
they watched it happen
or they let it happen.
And I just, that's really messed up
and I don't know how it
could, how someone could.
I'm not ready to forgive
them yet. (chuckling)
- [Mark] Yeah, well, you
can break the cycle then.
- I am.
I hope.
- [Mark] You still have
hope for your future?
- I can't say.
I wish I could say, yeah.
But a lot of times, no.
I just want it to end.
- All right Scarlett.
Well, I wish you the best of luck.
I hope you figure out a way out of here.
This is a dead end.
I mean, look around
and look at the people
that are older than you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] It's a hell of a
way to go with your life.
- [Scarlett] It is.
Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.
That was great.